Lauren Bushnell is dating singer Chris
Lane if you remember Lauren she was
engaged to Bachelor Ben Higgins they
then broke up she was dating somebody
else they split in August and now dating
country singer Chris Lane so this is
them on a red carpet in Nashville he's
there for the CMAs just last night our
own Cassie de Laura had seen this photo
told me about it and I reached out to
sources and found out yes we can confirm
exclusively that Chris and Lauren are
dating we also after that reached out to
Chris's rep he said yes they've been
dating it's new but they've been friends
for a couple years so these two dating
and happy and hopefully we're gonna get
Chris on the red carpet in Nashville
tonight's love this Jojo can I just ask
how tired is everybody on our news desk
right I know I got the fires we got the
batch I know news but you know what we
don't stop and I'd like stories like
this you know it could just be a red
carpet debut of a couple and it gets us
excited again you know and brand new
love we love it so so we don't mind we
don't mind and Chris and Lauren we kind
of we'd seen them flirting a little bit
on Instagram our eyebrows were raised
because I saw them commenting on each
other's instagrams now we're gonna try
to grab Chris on the red carpet tonight
so stay tuned to UT live for that and of
course
Jojo thank you for everything you're
doing I also want to flag tonight on ET
on the broadcast even more with the
bachelor mansion owner and so many other
big stories Jojo thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]